[Music]
Hollywood for a big old palace as you
know Prince Harry and mega Marco when
they continue to have everyone on
engagement watch and now it looks as if
there might be proof that in the
announcement could be coming soon
mehgan's reported a meeting with the
queen royal sources tell et that there
is no question that an engagement will
happen it's a matter of when and last
Thursday 33 year old Prince Harry
reportedly brought girlfriend mega
Merkel to an informal tea party with her
Royal Highness she's reported to have
shown up at Buckingham Palace around
five o'clock in the afternoon escorted
to the Queen's private living room
within Buckingham Palace and hosted to
tea certainly it's getting everyone very
excited Megan is currently in production
on the seventh season of suits for the
USA Network
but the 36 year old has reportedly
already told producers that she will not
be returning for season 8 further
fueling the rumors of an imminent royal
engagement if Megan did indeed meet the
Queen at Buckingham Palace in the
Queen's private living room that speaks
to a much bigger level of intimacy
between Megan and the Queen's of having
that one-on-one time as for when a
wedding to take place our sources tell
us it wouldn't happen until after the
birth of Prince William and Kate's third
baby Kate is due in April see I think
this is already a done deal they just
have to schedule it that's all ask if
you're making fans
you better believe
[Music]
you